First Nation
we are Partners in the joint venture
that owns the polar prints the polar
Prince is the sport vessel for the Ocean
Gate Expedition and is on scene in
supporting the rescue mission as
directed by the U.S Coast Guard in Ocean
Gate
today is National indigenous people stay
in Canada
Chief Joe we acknowledge this day for
you the Mi aboke First Nation and all
first peoples in Newfoundland and
Labrador and in Canada
on behalf of myself Chief Joe and
everyone at Miami Horizon Maritime
services and her hard times
I want to say first that our thoughts
and folks remain with the crew of the
Titan and their families
we wish to thank everyone involved in
this Rescue Mission especially the U.S
and Canadian Coast Guards the
organizations that have made their
Marine assets available including the
French government Technip FMC Atlantic
Towing doff
the many private companies who have
dropped everything at a moment's notice
and without hesitation and the various
Crews who are dedicated to bringing the
search and rescue mission to a
successful conclusion
in addition to the polar prints we have
also mobilized The Horizon Arctic to add
vessel support for this mission
we acknowledge and thank our client
Exxon Mobil who has without question
given the vessel the time and space
needed to respond to this incident
we also thank Premier Andrew Fury for
his continuous offers of support from
the province of Newfoundland and
Labrador
the Marine industry in this region is no
stranger to responding to difficult
incidents we work together to ensure
every possible effort is put into
bringing people home
the people on board the Titan and their
families are our Focus we care deeply
about their well-being all of us here in
Newfoundland and Labrador Canada the
United States and around the world are
unified in this work
while the United States Coast Guard in
cooperation with the Canadian Coast
Guard is leading this search and rescue
effort our critical role remains in a
support capacity
it has been a very difficult few days
for the crew and families of those on
board the Titan and the polar prints
the polar Prince captain and crew have
been steadfast in providing support
during this very difficult time
we have been supporting the Titanic
Expeditions for several years the polar
prints a 72 meter vessel remains at the
Titanic site participating in rescue
efforts the vessel is an iconic former
Canadian Coast Guard Icebreaker that has
been upgraded with advanced technology
and provides research and Expedition
Support Services to two clients
primarily in the Arctic
Horizon purchased the polar prints in
The Horizon Arctic is also involved in
this Mission the 94 meter vessel is one
of the most powerful and versatile
offshore support vessels in the world
often working internationally this
Canadian flag vessel has recently
performed rig moves offshore wind
infrastructure installations
and seabed surveys before returning to
Newfoundland and Labrador for a seasonal
project this summer
The Horizon Arctic was on route to the
site on Sunday and then returned to port
and St John's to pick up deep water
equipment
late last night the Arctic crew loaded a
U.S ROV which thanks to the U.S military
arrived by air to St John's airport late
yesterday
The Vessel Departed the port of St
John's at 5 a.m this morning and will
arrive at the Titanic site tomorrow
morning
we are very aware of the time
sensitivity around this mission
our crews and onshore team are experts
in their fields and will continue to
support this effort in every way we can
we remain focused on contributing to the
search for the Titan crew and continue
to hold out hope that they will be
located and brought home safely
Chief Joe
thank you Sean
thank you all for being here too as well
my name is uh Chief missaldo I'm from
the my book of First Nation and on the
south coast of Newfoundland
and I can tell you
that are we are our people are very
concerned uh for the crew of the Titan
we're proud of the Polar prints
its crew and worked as done as does this
remarkable Bissell
who have no doubt that the Captain Crew
have been handling themselves without
most expertise and professionalism
throughout this difficult time
also want to thank Sean
and the support team here at Horizon for
all they're doing support the search
search and rescue operations
I've been in constant contact with the
operation team that the company has been
reaching out to prayer groups across the
country
to bring the hope and to this effort we
are praying for our friends on board a
Titan submersible
we want them to come home
they want them to come home safely we
asked everyone across Canada in the
world
to pray with us that we can't find the
rescue the risk of the Titan
thank you
so the U.S Coast Guard's leading the
search and rescue effort as you know
we're taking our direction for them and
all the communications are flowing back
through them they had a fairly in-depth
conference about an hour and a half ago
I think and they've covered all that so
we have nothing further dad
the North Atlantic is always a
challenging place especially in in the
region that we're in uh the weather is
is not overly significant at this point
but but it always presents a challenge
in the region
the equipment that's been mobilized for
this is um is the finest in the world uh
the most capable in the world we have to
hold out hope I think as you're aware
there's still life support available on
the submersible and we'll continue to
hold all hope until the very end
all I can tell you there is all
protocols were followed from the mission
on this ship any of that that you can
provide us
these are extremely professional and
experienced Crews this is an
unprecedented situation but I can assure
you that they're handling their
responsibilities very professionally and
fully focused on trying to find the
submersible and bring those people back
safely
right now during the search domestic
operations can you tell us a little bit
about that that's the question I can't
answer what support are you giving me
the U.S Coast Guards leading the search
and rescue effort and oh that's being
fun for you it's Sean Horizon Maritime
does a lot of different things in the
world this is one of them but I take it
this community this exploration it
sounds like their colleagues they've
been here for many years their friends
their family to you guys what is that
you do a lot of things but what is this
one this situation like
core values of the advocac Horizon
Maritime services and the rise of
Maritime Services is customer focused
and we're focused on all our customers
and all the various missions we operate
making sure that they're carried out
with about
[Music]
is there anything out there that's
capable of of lifting this thing up from
the depth that it's presumed to be and
bringing it back to the service there's
a lot of variability around the question
you're asking there but the equipment
that is on site and coming to site is
the most capable of the world and some
of that equipment is certainly capable
of reaching those depths how much time
do you think there's left to be able to
if if you were to have success how much
oxygen is left how much time is there
left to be able to actually these people
out to get them out a lot there's
variability around that question as well
Patrick it's it's uh it's difficult to
for me to give you any more detail than
the US Coast Guard has already provided
in their brief can you tell us to see
exactly what time your vessel at the
polar prints launched
the type exactly specifically what time
Sunday morning
uh I I don't have that off the top of my
head I'm sorry can you tell us about the
sense of urgency last night with getting
the gear off the aircraft
um down here with the police escort and
onto the ship and out of here can you
talk us through that with the people who
are working yeah I've been in the Marine
industry since a very young age and seen
a lot of different situations and I've
never seen equipment of that nature move
that quickly the response from the U.S
Coast Guard the U.S military the folks
at the airport
um the the people here various companies
were involved in the mobilization of
that equipment to the Arctic it was done
flawlessly can you give us more details
about what kind of equipment that was
it's a deep water early and can you tell
us how long will the polar prints stay
search area with
how long can it stay how long will it
stay out during the search efforts it'll
it'll stay out until the search is
completed
Sean can you talk about what if any
community
friends and the vessel had before uh it
missed the timeline that it was supposed
to meet for surfacing at the sea level
what if any communication did the bullet
prints have with the vessel before they
there was regular Communications up
until a point and and then I think as
you're aware they um their their
communication ceased can you just expand
on what regular means where you was the
crew doing well was everything going as
planned was there any moment where they
communicated that they were in any sort
of distress or having any sort of issues
I'm not aware of any details around that
case search right now but there's been a
a lot of concerns raised already about
about the safety of this and what ocean
gate was doing did you consider that
when you partnered with Ocean Gate
welcome Ocean Gate runs an extremely
safe operation
our full Focus right now is getting that
submersible located and getting those
people brought back safely at what point
did at what point did communication
cease
when
um when they were
diving to the Titanic at some point but
do you have a timeline on that
specifically when you lost communication
could you just tell us a little bit
about how often you're in contact okay
just one more question just how often
you're in contact with the crew of The
Polar prints and what kind of
information are you getting from them
we're in constant contact with the crew
of The Polar Prince um our emergency
procedures kicked in immediately our
emergency room next door is Staff 24 7
with uh with a group of extremely
capable people and there's uh live
communication how many crew or Court out
there
on your how many groups
uh we've got 17 crew on board Sean why
did
why did it for the